la question d'aujourd'hui c'est comment
améliorer significativement sa connexion
internet à la maison
comment amener comment améliorer à son
wifi comment faire que tout ça marche
mieux tout ça se passe beaucoup mieux
avec une très bonne collection bien
répartis et ce quel que soit votre
maison quelle que soit votre intérieur
quel que soit votre configuration le
nombre de pièces l'épaisseur des murs
tout ça on s'en fout et pour ça on a une
solution c'est ça signée tp-link voilà
la problématique
vous avez une maison ça c'est une maison
dans cette maison vous avez plusieurs
étage par étage
vous avez plusieurs pièces je sais on
dirait des briques
ici vous avez votre connexion internet
qui arrivent ici internet j'écris
toujours très très bien vous avez donc
ici votre box où vous allez pouvoir
avoir un signal qui va rayonner dans
votre maison
mais plus vous allez vous éloignez est
bon vous y avoir une connexion mais si
par exemple vous avez ici une chambre à
coucher
je sais que c'est très très bien une
chambre à coucher avec une personne qui
est couché là et qui va surfer sur son
téléphone de soi et bien il captera très
très mal atteindrait du coup qu'est ce
qu'il vous faut il vous pouvoir emmener
votre connexion internet jusque là et
c'est l'âme de solutions intervient
parce qu'en fait elle vous permet
d'installer un petit boîtier par étage
par exemple un ici vous allez pouvoir
ensuite en installer un autre ici une
fois de plus c'est extrêmement rien vous
voyez où votre signal va rayonner de
tous les côtés pour pouvoir diffuser
internet partout sauf que si si c'est
très épais et bien vous aurez une moins
bonne collection ici et vous allez
installer une fois de plus un petit
boitier je sais pas voir par exemple ici
qui vous permettra de diffuser internet
très facilement partout et surtout de
manière homogène
je sais je sais je suis ni picasso
dibango je ne dessine pas très très bien
j'ai que dessine aussi bien écrit mais
bon au moins comme ça vous arrive à
comprendre l'idée ça ces principes
sauf que si vous avez votre connexion
qui se fait en wifi c'est à dire vous
partez de votre signal qui est là et lui
va récupérer le wifi delà pour ensuite
envoyer le signal et lui parle aussi
pour l'envoyer et bien c'est bien mais
c'est pas complètement dingue le mieux
c'est ce que vous propose justement fils
public avec sa solution le des copines
parce que le d'écoper 9
c'est plutôt pas mal s'associent de
techno qu'on arrive à combiner ensemble
complètement optimisé l'histoire c'est à
dire du wifi mesh et de l'autre côté des
cpl comment ça marche tout ça pour
prendre création on a donc le signale
ici en wifi pour avoir un bon il fit ici
ça marche bien sauf que pour vous
emmener ici la collection internet ce
qu'il faut faire c'est passé par
l'électricité
ici vous avez votre circuit électrique
maginot votre circuit électrique
il parle là il va jusqu ici et il va
continuer à monter et il va arriver
jusqu'ici
là on parle bien de l'électricité vous
avez votre box qui est situé ici vous
allez brancher votre déco p9 ici lui il
va être branché directement en ethernet
à votre box est à dire qu il est relié
par un câble
donc on ya quelque chose qui est
complètement optimisé mais lui par
contre il est branché sur la prise
électrique pour pouvoir une être
alimentés et de deux pour pouvoir
envoyer le signal c'est à dire le signal
internet dans vos câbles électriques
sans absolument aucune déperdition
électrique alors pour ça il vous faut
installations électriques qui sont assez
récentes pour qu'ils aient pas de
déperdition ça veut dire que vous avez
le signal internet qui arrive à votre
deuxième d'écoper neuf ici sans
absolument aucune sphère lui donne un
pouvoir retransmettre du wifi avec la
même qualité que si vous étiez à côté de
la boxe et c'est exactement la même
chose lorsque vous allez arriver ici au
dernier étage lui va récupérer aussi
toutes les informations internes est
absolument aucune perte dans la mesure
où grâce à la scion est récente à
pouvoir communiquer en wifi avec la même
qualité que si vous étiez beauté de
notre box alors ça c'est pas de la magie
mais presque vous combinez donc du wifi
mesh les cpl pour avoir collé sur
internet homogène complètement optimisé
quelles que soient les p5 vos murs quels
que soient les auteurs votre immeuble
quel que soit votre installation quelle
que soit la configuration de votre
maison et ça marche merveilleusement
bien je vous montre à la mairie comment
j'ai fait ici le studio il est en
dessous d'une habitation c'est à dire
que juste au dessus c'est là où j'habite
et gelé mis juste la voyez il est juste
brancher à une prise électrique qui est
planqué quelque part par derrière voilà
il est connecté à internet ça navigue
directement la voyez n'y a pas grand
chose les deux prises ethernet sont
complètement libéré et ici c'est tout ça
veut donc dire que ma connexion internet
qu'elle arrive pardon câbles
d'alimentation électrique depuis l'étagé
supérieur chez moi internet c'est
branché dans le placard à balais c'est
un placard il ya des balles et un
placard à balais donc ici j'ai ma box de
bouygues telecom nous arrive directement
tout signal internet et vous avez ici
voyez monde et coppenolle de tp link ça
c'est le le numéro un c'est le principal
il est branché directement au port
ethernet de la boxe on a donc ici un
signe et internet qui complètement
optimisé donc par dc du wifi pour tous
les objets qui vont être connectés qui
sont à sa portée
et ensuite il va redistribuer le signal
par la prise électrique tac tac tac tac
tac tac qui est planqué ici derrière les
balais parce que oui il faut de plus
c'est un placard à balais et qui va être
récupérée par les prises électriques
jeumont la suite au sort du placard à
balais en continu dans la maison qu'on
arrive par ici et si vous voyez on veut
retrouver une autre qui est planqué ici
juste derrière le joli pot de fleur
d'épée nique et lui il n'est pas du tout
branché sur un câble ethernet comme
l'autre en bas il est branché uniquement
ici et on le voit de par la couleur il
est au km h donc que ce soit ici ou que
ce soit dans le studio toute la
collection internet arrivent directement
par les cris cité c'est un système cpl
et ensuite va distribuer internet en
wifi on a donc ici une solution qui est
extrêmement flexible très souple que
vous pouvez adapter complètement à la
configuration de votre maison ou de
votre appartement
la conséquence c'est que toute votre
habitation va être couverte d'un point
de vue réseau il y aura pas de zone nord
pas de zones d'ombré j'ai des
informations très très très technique
que j'ai noté ici avec chaque boîtier va
couvrir 185 mètres carrés grâce au wifi
et si vous combinez les trois ça vous
donne donc 560 mètres carrés ce qui vous
couvre quand même globalement des élans
habitat sur tout ça c'est bien mais ça
ne s'arrête pas là puisque vous avez une
application qui vous sert à connecter
vos boîtiers et à gérer votre collection
internet l'application s'est elle déco
vous l'ouvrez et vous pouvez monitorer
ce qui se passe chez vous alors ici pour
l'instant j'ai deux divas de se
connecter
j'ai mon iphone que vous avez ici sous
les yeux et j'ai mon macbook pro donc
pouvoir en ma consommation descendante
est ascendante internet extrêmement
facilement et ça avec tous mes appareils
connectés
si j'ai mon réseau qui est là mais je
peux en avoir d'autres si je le souhaite
j'ai ici tout mais alerté toutes mes
informations sur les nouveaux appareils
qui viennent de se connecter
je peux venir connecter un nouvel
appareil si je le souhaite en ajouter
donc ça c'est un aperçu global et si je
veux aller plus loin je vais non plus
alors dans plus je vends la gestion de
mon wifi g le nombre au réseau mon mot
de passe peut venir partager extrêmement
facilement gmail liste noire des
appareils que je souhaite black listés
ici il y en a au coeur tu peux mettre à
jour mon d'écho chez moi il est déjà à
jour n'ont cure absolument aucun souci
mais j'ai des paramètres avancés puisque
j'ai réussi à savoir quel ip je veux
avoir ipv4 ipv6 bon et pas mal de choses
que vous avez pas venir vous couchez
notre relation voler plus loin on peut
le faire un contrôle parental alors
personnellement je n'ai pas qu'yves et
vu que elliott à six ans pour l'instant
il va pas se connecter à internet ou
vraiment lorsqu'on va lui donner et
retiré device vous regardez quelques
dessins animés mais pas plus que ça si
vous souhaitez vous paramétrez
différents profils son contrôle parental
et bien vous pouvez le faire toute la
gestion de la qualité de service bon
vous avez aussi un rapport mensuel pour
le voir qui sont les administrateurs et
les gérer en gros vous avez vraiment une
vue d'ensemble pour tout pilote
extrêmement facilement bon alors on va
le dire ok tout ça c'est bien je vais
pouvoir avoir un combiné du wifi mesh
combiné des cpl mais tout ça va être
très compliqué installé je vais y aller
à il va falloir venir
configurez de différences apparaissent
avec la guérilla et bien en fait c'est
très simple je vous explique comment ça
marche vous prenez votre premier boîtier
vous allez le brancher électriquement ça
marche parce que sinon ça ne marchera
pas vous allez le brancher en ethernet à
votre box ou à votre routeur si vous en
avez un peu importe vous vous branchez
donc pour le connecter à internet
ensuite vous allez grain ces petites
applications que vous aurez téléchargé
vont bien sûr vous créez un compte chez
tp leak eut avoué cette petite
application
et bien vous allez vous connecter avec
votre smartphone directement sur le wifi
qui est générée par votre déco p 9
il est marqué au dos très facile il est
marqué d'écoper de quelque chose c'est
vraiment facile vous vous connectez
l'application le reconnaît et elle
synchronise directement à votre hauteur
vous avez donc première connexion wifi
qui se fait comme ça vous branche et le
deuxième sens n'importe quelle prise
électrique de votre habitation dans la
mesure où ce sont mêmes réseaux
électriques
une facile à clignoter en bleu vous
cliquez sur ajouter qu est ce qu est
automatiquement ça vous permet de
connecter autant d'appareils que vous
voulez
très facilement sans aucune compétence
particulière donc ça c'est plutôt bien
bien évidemment le prérequis c'est
d'avoir du débit internet
si vous avez une connexion adsl un peu
moisie et bien ça ne sera pas magique ce
que vous avez à la source est ce que
vous allez pouvoir redistribuer dans
votre intérieur
ce que je vous conseille quand même
c'est avoir une connexion de bonne
qualité si on peut avoir de la fibre
c'est carrément mieux c'est vraiment
optimales à coup d'état si vous avez en
adsl vous aurez une meilleure
répartition en wifi grâce à ses bottés
là que grâce à votre box adsl un peu
standard bien évidemment vous pouvez
connecter plein d'appareils ensemble sur
des tablettes des ordinateurs pour faire
du gaming pour des rites et par tout ce
que vous voulez je vous permettra
d'avoir un haut débit complètement
homogène chez vous tels que soient les
pièces lorsque vous allez vous promener
dans votre maison passer d'un étage à
l'autre changer de pièce et ce quel que
soit une fois de plus l'épaisseur des
murs se sera complètement invisible pour
vous est ce que ça sera le même nom
réseau votre smartphone par exemple si
vous avez un smartphone si vous vous
baladez dans la maison c'est mieux que
ce pari avec une telle est toujours plus
compliqué eh bien il va se connecter au
d'écoper 9 le plus proche avec le
meilleur signal et pour vous ce sera
complètement invisible puisque vous sont
toujours sur le même réseau sera
toujours le même mot de passe
donc ça c'est vachement bien quoi comme
je vous le disais si vous avez de la
fibre chez vous ça va tartiner un max
grâce au wifi mesh vous pouvez aller
jusqu'à 1200 mégabits par seconde et
grâce au cpl jusqu'à 1000 megabit par
seconde
vous pouvez connecter jusqu'à 100
appareils dessus et en plus ce qui est
bien c'est que vous avez une garantie 3
ans donc si vous avez un problème vous
êtes au moins couverts et tranquille
pendant trois ans et si vous avez
d'autres appareils de tp link chez vous
amène un plat et si vous avez d'autres
appareils de tp link chez vous quelles
que soient par comme si vous avez ici en
routeur tp-link nous allons pouvoir
l'ailier très facilement ensemble tout
ça grâce à votre compte tpx plutôt cool
c'est un réseau maillé c'est pratique ça
marche bien c'est sympa moi je trouve ça
cool dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire est-ce que
vous avez chez vous en réseaux wifi qui
n'est pas de bonne qualité est-ce que
vous avez des problèmes de collection
est ce que le fait d'avoir des murs un
peu épais ça peut être compliqué ce que
vous avez des maisons avec plusieurs
étages est arrivé un moment et bien vous
ne captez plus rien ou à des zones
d'ombré
c'est la grosse galère et est ce que
vous pensez que cette solution tp-link
d'écoper neuf pourrait vous aider si
c'est le cas et jetta me le marquer en
bas en commentaires qu en est il du prix
qu'en est il du free monsieur re
bien voilà c'est là où c'est à dire très
intéressant à regarder je mets mes
feuilles de tous les côtés salah ce
petit pack le pack de trois ça coûte 200
9 euros alors c'est une certaine somme
mais croyez moi que ça vraiment dire
solutionner tous les problèmes internet
à la maison
rendez vous lundi derrière ce joli
schéma qui vous explique comment ça
marche c'est mieux je sais que c'est
beaucoup mieux que ça mais ça c'est fait
maison
donc ça c'est plutôt cool je vous invite
donc à me dire tout ça en commentaire me
parlez de vos problématiques de 8 fixé
aux intérêts sera bien évidemment un
lien en bas dans la description sur ce
je vous fais des gros bisous on va
beaucoup d'amour je donne rendez vous
dès demain pour continuer à parler de
taka les bisous amour adam un toit
[Musique]
on